All right.
Welcome everybody.
Hope you're having a great day.
Back to computer vision and
were continuing with our work and
particle filters.
Last time we introduced
particle filtering and
we talked about the algorithm
that actually implemented it.
So were using a set of
particles representing density.
And we went through the base loop of
essentially propagating the belief
forward through about the deterministic
and non-deterministic part.
Then we get a measurement
which gives us a likelihood.
We multiply the,
the prediction by that likelihood and
that gives us something in Bay's rule
that we can normalize to have a new
belief, a new posterior
estimate of the state.
So, in this lesson, we're going to look
at some, robot vision examples that,
sort of illustrate nicely, sort of,
the simplicity of using this method.